[Music]
in unique business news submitted by
hellige Wharf this 20 this 28 year-old
brings in six figures a year selling
potatoes online Wow
what kind of potatoes is it like
potatoes that are shaped like
celebrities yeah these are bags of
potatoes oh no I mean no I'm gonna mr.
Potato Head nope seeds okay they are
potatoes that shaped like special
potatoes they are special there's
something special about them
sure yes or no I got it no he peels them
first no what is it
no one gets it there are potatoes shoes
hey - bet you serious dude actually I'm
not even gonna tell you they're they're
they're from they're from Ireland
they're imported from Ireland no I'll
let them tell you so they were on Sharky
bones no no you for all are you joking
right okay okay I really can't tell at
this point I was singing the Shark Tank
song I thought the song dance dance
dance yeah yeah yeah I love I love
watching people like go like hi so I
have this app I don't have any followers
on it yet but I'm giving em for 1% or 5%
of my company 2 million dollars it's
like shut the [ __ ] up dude all right
here we go now you guys will find out
ohh
already yeah they look like two dicks
here we go
is that what you dick looks like that's
wrong by sharks my name is Alex Craig
and I'm riad Beckett I guys are we
discussed you is seeking $50,000 in
exchange for 10% equity in our business
look come on let's be the Sharks over
the years you've heard all types of
elaborate intricate and over at the top
pitches well we're here to keep it
simple so let's take this pitch back to
our roots
sharks our company is potato parcel and
we male potatoes and that's it
any questions so potato parcel is a
brand-new way of sending anyone you know
a custom message written on a potato did
they get a deal
No one of the Sharks would be like what
the [ __ ] yeah when a shark said sign on
which one yeah um Kevin O'Leary
oh my god it would be Kevin now who's a
troll mr. wonderful yeah mr. wonderful
yeah he's such a [ __ ] troll there he
is he has so much money go this is dumb
I just won I could just give who cares
but I love him because he's like the
most brutal and honest and but you know
why you know I feel like he probably did
it too because he he always also signs
on to the deals or he feels like let's
make the money quick and get out yeah
there's like a novelty thing where
people buy it as a gift and then it's
like put some money yeah yeah exactly
and then he'll then he'll be like I
wanna make this much back and then and
then as long as I make my money back and
make a little bit extra like you got to
do you know yeah they just do this where
they write messages and send them to
people some good handwriting and they're
making six figures hmm that's pretty
tight not that but it look like a baby
I'm surprised I don't even buy this yeah
I would buy this [ __ ] I could see myself
sending somebody a potato with message
on it yeah I would just do it myself
doing yeah daddy's go to Rob's and fire
potato right on it to get broth [ __ ]
I go to a person's a barbecue thing I
would do this I would do this if the
packaging made it look like it's gonna
be some dope-ass chocolate or roses or
something and then you open it it's just
a potato it's like a troll president I
still feel like the most genius business
venture that I've seen so far is the air
he can air and I can I'm like with the
Beijing amazing yeah have you seen that
yeah that Canada Beijing you have
multiple you open it and you could oh I
missed it I missed it they sell the
Beijing air though because that's all
smog you might miss it it might move to
like Yosemite you know it man I need
some pollution today that's backs though
whenever I'm in an area that's too fresh
I don't like it for more than like a few
days I'm like I need some smog and my
system dude I don't feel right feels too
clean
yeah when I'm when I'm out there I'm
like it's too fresh your lungs all spun
to get nice and [ __ ] yeah I can feel
them a helium like yeah you need to get
a cigar or something
I felt like that about food when we went
to Italy because everything was like
super fresh ingredients like where's the
purse weird yeah that's what it was like
going to Vegas we're in Vegas five four
days right okay I'll like do this air so
crisp 40 the biggest way to long Vegas
like it gives you nose bleeds after like
the fifth day because of just house and
then at the sixth day you got a lung
cancer even if you're not a smoker Brett
I don't know why you're being vague is
that long that's crazy I know I love it
I could be different month yeah really
there's so much you don't know how to
live go off-roading you could hike the
mountains and look down at the strip
there's so much [ __ ] to do [ __ ]
Brandi yeah you got yoga gamble a lot
you could gamble like a mofo I only like
Vegas if you guys go Vegas in general I
don't know how to do it okay you know
what that's true because when we talk
when I talk about Vegas I'm thinking of
let's go turn up for three days and you
know you're [ __ ] up for three days I
don't turn up once me neither
yeah I forget that there's as I got
older you gotta come with us I will
cuz like once I got older and I started
getting like money and it was like I was
introduced to the not turn up side of
Vegas where there's acts like really
nice restaurants the shows are dope
massage
solar mockingly area the attractions
there's something called the mob museum
you're not missing out yeah yeah you are
it's awesome
do you like Goodfellas no I'm nothing
like casino I like I like mob movies
yeah yeah yeah it's [ __ ] dope have
y'all seen Oh at the Bellagio yeah
that's the [ __ ] wave this [ __ ]
mind-blowing isn't it it was the most
gayest thing I've ever seen the manatees
cool but like it's certain in terms of a
Cirque du Soleil show always yo always
cuz this is tight the whole time or like
someone's [ __ ] dying any second that's
why they call it all cuz your butthole
yeah and cuz you're having a Oh about
the Blue Man Group
do I want to see them still there's so
many things that we still haven't seen I
saw boys 2 men I went to a boy Simon's
oh yeah see that's another thing it's a
great place to relive the 90s we went we
saw Al Green did but that was that prim
there's a perimeter this [ __ ]
was wiping his sweat off and [ __ ] of
licking at the front row oh my god
[ __ ] loved it it was disgusting
these old women will get any horniest
but there were throwing pennies do
granny panties no daddy were there what
control that out there like this big
really it took 30 seconds to come down
that [ __ ] was crazy sinless I was
sitting next to a 90 year old dinosaur
that was [ __ ] like oxygen taking
everything and then when her song came
to
and she got up and started yeah like
what she had a heart attack yeah [ __ ]
800 potatoes not but the other cool yeah
we got multiples yeah so they have you
can plant them potato just a message for
10 bucks they have a birthday bundle
face I would put someone's face on a
potato that's you know that's pretty
cool and then a postcard for 13 the
prize one and then even sell candy just
I hey we still can t good yeah this is a
random a Berlin so we got big league
chew so you wanna buy it is the jam I
loved it I felt like I could play
baseball now dad man if I make a [ __ ]
ton of money I want to make like lobster
tank or some [ __ ] and then I just sit
there and then and people like try to
pitch the most craziest ideas and all
the sensible business ones I'm like [ __ ]
you are boring I'll probably make a lot
of money but hate myself move and then
someone comes up in like oh I'm gonna be
selling [ __ ] water
but like polluted waters it's got to be
like the most ridiculous ideas like this
like that like you guys like create your
own invention like since you were a kid
or whatever you're big you know what we
really should have something dude I had
a bunch of invention invention I and
what happened oh me too I remember had a
[ __ ] ton and then I would see them get
made
are they were they probably really
existed I was just like I was thinking
the same thing I know it's right you
never know the nester she cracks me up
she always says I have million-dollar
ideas and they existed for years it's so
[ __ ] funny she gets hyped about it
too
she'll check this out you know everybody
hates doing laundry right
what if somebody came to your house I
just took it to the dry cleaner I was
like you mean like this happier it's
called washer full service but you can
have it at my apartment complex we have
a [ __ ] locker suit um just throw
[ __ ] in there and then they come pick it
up yeah so what if you could call
somebody who had their own car and they
active the taxi service to pick you up
and I'll call it Boober topless tapas
uber oh my god okay makes sense though
why me because they're driving you back
no but you get to reach around and grab
on them that's dangerous uber again
mirrors I got it it's called a sir and
what happens is the seat is clear so you
can just see ass all throughout the ride
oh oh you mean like the drivers no but
if they're really hot like temperature
whoo hot and then it's off like see me
oh you can't see the ass anymore and
it's just like a pot because I've been
sitting and it's just a puddle of water
yeah that's pretty yucky booty juice is
what we call it Rudy juice I always said
igloo delivery service so you get igloo
ship from the North Pole mm-hmm to
California during the summer because
it's really hot but they're gonna have
to buy one every year the lobster thing
baby yes cuz if it melts right so it
only lasts you know so today you
actually that's bad like if they found a
way to transport a [ __ ] igloo to you
just put on your yard and like just for
the novelty of it chill for like a walk
yeah dude and then don't have dad to get
another one every year that the vital
like lobster tank it's like you and then
like four other like dudes just chilling
on lawn chairs with like some of the
Bands broken and shares this flapping
down song right now for a dude
[Music]
[Music]